welcome to another episode of apocalypse
never we're only here at this moment
this very dangerous moment because of
Donald Trump's impulses we're at the
early stages of a hot war it is a
monumental moment this is absolutely
insane and it's going to draw us into
that region in a way that we absolutely
cannot afford war with Iran is madness
and it is strategically and morally a
disaster that would have widened and
exploded the Middle East into a war like
we've never seen that strike has
predictably predictably with an
exclamation point kicked a hornet's nest
in the Middle East predictably
predictably what a convulsion of chuckle
buckets they were so ready for
Armageddon because then that would all
be on Trump I haven't seen that much
wishful thinking since Michael Moore
tried on leather pants but as usual the
end took a rain check
bummer Don Lemon had just installed a
foot bath and his fallout shelter and
Chris Cuomo just stored all his
remaining Botox in his face but did that
stop the stupid hell no in an effort to
maintain the anti-trump narrative one
dolt compared Soleimani to lady die when
Princess Diana died for example there
was a huge emotional outpouring these
kinds of Elvis Presley in our culture it
turns out that this generally killed was
a beloved hero of the Iranian people to
the point we look at the people who got
pictures up now these enormous crowds
coming out there's no American emotion
in this case but there's a hell of a lot
of emotion on the other side oh my god
lady lady die Elvis I think Chris that's
been smelling too many of Eric's well
wells farts
the point is though you better not kill
a bad guy because then he'll become a
martyr I guess from now on we only send
angry letters to their local paper or
maybe a strongly-worded poem recited by
Deepak Chopra at the UN so here's the
theory that's gonna blow your mind why
is it when Trump uses any force the
critics go nuts because as even the New
York Times admits Trump has used
military force less than any president
since Jimmy Carter which is why why the
media hysterically amplifies it because
it's so rare so when it happens they
have to milk it for all it's worth now
you see it I get it I do the same thing
when once a year my wife gets a little
drunk I make I make a huge deal out of
it because I may never get the chance
again but the media will take any chance
to call Trump a fascist example a ranch
shoots down a Ukrainian passenger plane
and who to the media and Dems blame
Trump I mean I really rands not even
blaming him but she is if what is being
projected is true this is yet another
example of collateral damage from the
actions that have been taken in a
provocative way by the president United
States imagine idiots like this after
Pearl Harbor you know maybe if you
didn't have all those shiny boats out
there which are used for war this
wouldn't have happened it's fun watching
Trump force Democrats to defend stuff no
actual human would defend here's the
view applauding white racists I love
that I mean I could just say the view
and everybody's hearts thing
but here they are applauding white
bigots because now they both hate Trump
what's some good news this is a timing
thing that I noticed you remember
Richard Spencer he's basically the
organizer of unite the Ryan attack the
white nationalist group that was
marching in Charlottesville it's all in
for Trump not anymore
his his quote he tweeted last night I
deeply regret voting for and promoting
Donald Trump in 2016
oh my gosh Wow plenty white supremacists
I think the tiny thing joy noticed was
her brain I can't wait to see the views
hour long tribute to the Boston bomber
after he calls Trump a weenie but that's
a lid juicing politics over morality
from Weinstein to Epstein to Clinton
every Pig gets a pass and now so do
murderous generals so Iran launched
missiles into space somewhere between an
American base and a Kmart in Cleveland
and then they declared it over then they
called it proportionate to the killing
of their top general imagine that it's
like they deliberately whiffed on three
pitches then trotted around the bases
like they hit a home run I mean if
you're Salah manis ghosts you got to be
pissed
that's the send-off it's a weird message
from Iran that maybe we got rid of a guy
who was a pain in their neck - for Iran
it's like finding out your car got
stolen and it was a beat-up 72 Corolla
you know you were trying to get rid of
it for a year so you parked it in a bad
neighborhood with the keys in the
ignition
that was Salamone so sorry media
it's a thinker sorry media it was an
Operation Desert Shield
it was more like operation desert rash
the press conference lasted longer so I
wonder should the American people be
extremely grateful and happy no
Americans were harmed the American
people should be extremely grateful and
happy no Americans were harmed in last
night's attack by the Iranian regime for
now and that is a good outcome of course
his critics are pissed he didn't give
them a heads-up but maybe he didn't have
time to call up Nancy who was not
operating with a full deck we didn't
have time to call up Nancy who is not
operating with a full deck
you could tell and would you tell Schiff
after all he is a big leaker Jeff is a
big leaker he leaks too crazy CNN see
with a little red light our chief tisha
Seiji Adam how you do it listen we have
the world's number one terrorist we've
lined up Adam and it's loose look no one
wants war but who we saw wasn't war and
unlike the median Democrats we aren't
stuck in a prison of two ideas where
it's either do nothing or its World War
three no in between those prisons is the
turf that trump navigates so well
between nothing and everything Trump
chose a decisive action that solved a
horrible problem not bad but then again
he always said he could be more
presidential I always say I can be more
presidential than any candidate that
ever ran than any president other than
maybe Abraham Lincoln what he's wearing
his hat
let's welcome tonight's guest he's as
American as a president Dave mattress
sale Fox & Friends weekend codes pizza
he's on the FBI's at least wanted list
comedian Joe Mackey her laugh is
contagious but so is her cough host of
sincerely katha Fox Asian gets in and
the stork that delivered him got a
hernia my massive sidekick in host
enough setup box agent Cyrus
Peet's what do you think of this week
who would eat cow well yeah what do you
think this is done is it over what do
you see how of course it's not done
yeah because Iran's not done I mean
their entire regime is premise Thanh
exporting terrorism they are not done
they can't they can't live without it I
was actually in favor
honestly in favor of much stronger
strikes against the Iranian regime
listen they're still racing for nuclear
bomb yeah you're going to and you can't
live in a world where they have it right
so I felt like now's a good time to take
that next step really not you got that
was my belief now the president went the
other way and good for him and you know
why I trust and support him it's the
same reason why you you trust and
supported a Ronald Reagan back in the
day because you know where is core is
you know what he believes you know he
has the defense of the American people
in mind whereas you could never believe
that with Jimmy Carter or Barack Obama
you knew they would appease away who we
are in this case you know Trump at the
end of the day is gonna have our
country's back in this case he doesn't
think this is the right time to do it
and Iran knows yeah you take one more
drop of American blood and you're done
it's just amazing how much
I mean I guess we already knew but who
knew the Democrats hated America this
much if you were to build a list of the
people to kill it would be like the
leader of Hezbollah Kim jong-un and
Qasem Soleimani yeah and yet this isn't
good enough yeah it's amazing you know
Joe I love watching Trump force
Democrats to defend weird stuff like the
view applauding like Richard Spencer
white supremacists I would I would like
to thank the ladies of the view because
every time I do this show I'm terrified
that I'm gonna say something stupid
about politics but they're perfectly
calm and they say something stupid every
day
[Laughter]
I love the part when they go that's
really good and then he stopped any Oh
interesting
they were like they were all they were
all on board maybe he'll be a regular
guest on the view the hot seat
whenever you great no all right we'll
move on then cat what are your thoughts
of this week what's your analysis your
cat analysis I always thought one yeah
okay well you know last week I was the
one person on the couch who said I did
have some concerns about this whole
thing yes but it seems like everything
is just fine and I'm happy about that
yes right the interesting thing is
there's a lot of people on the Left who
I don't think they can say that they're
disappointed that it didn't go well
it's but I'm the one hand I get it right
when someone hurts you they've been hurt
by Trump when someone hurts you you
don't want them to accomplish things and
be happy like whenever I hear that my
ex-boyfriend has a comedy show yes I
want him to do terribly okay but if I
knew that him doing terribly meant there
would be like this huge war and all
these innocent people being blown up
like I would think about it but
ultimately I would decide like no I want
everyone to live yeah I want him to do
well I want and but but they were like
almost disappointed they wanted that the
to just be like ah ha see I told you
yeah but they don't realize they
wouldn't even be able to have that
moment of gloating because they'd be
being blown up
yes that's true I would just like to say
in defense of the view I don't think
she'd Kluber Cruiser with Whoopi
Goldberg drop
watch if you watch the body language
won't be was like do we hate him that
much
yes because if President Trump lost
support of white supremacist that
actually in a weird way pleases me
something young racist
where the racists were like the hell
with this guy how is that yeah if he's
somebody on there would have said it had
to been miss McCain to say isn't that a
good thing yeah we'll be right back
after commercial she wouldn't be there
but that's the point
it literally America the world is so
great afraid of our crazy president yeah
that he will kill your general and get
back you will blow up the parking lot
but not the one that's marked off yeah
just the shopping carts that nobody was
going to bring back in anyway yeah
that's what Iran is